foreign
Josh how are you
doing great how you doing Dave better
than I deserve what's up
so question for you my wife and I have a
household income of just over a hundred
thousand and we're completely through
baby steps one through three and I'm
wondering how with the current house
market we don't have a home or saving up
for a home how do baby steps four and
five change for us
why would they change
are we are just saving up for a home and
working towards that down payment we're
almost ready for the down payment okay
have you ever heard us talk about the
thing we call baby step 3B
I have heard a little bit yes okay
that's what you're talking about I think
okay so you finish your emergency fund
at three that is the point at which you
would begin to save for your home and
some people Push pause and don't do four
and don't start saving for retirement
until they build their fully until they
get their house down payment some people
save for a house while they're putting
something in retirement up to 15 for
baby step four so you can do either one
or both somewhere in there so how long
is this going to take to save up your
down payment
I think in mid next year we're going to
have a little bit larger down payment
than is required and we're doing eight
percent of our household income into
roths right now okay and so while doing
eight percent you'll still have that
down payment by mid next year
yeah we're putting away eight percent
into the rocks and about 40 of savings
just goes away into CDs until we're
ready for our down payment that's
fabulous Josh well done yeah that's what
we would call baby step 3B so 3B is all
of your savings goes into
um
into your house down payment fund up or
down to a little bit less a little bit
less a little bit less than all because
you're putting some or up to 15 in the
retirement so you're putting eight into
retirement and you're still going to
make your down payment goals doesn't
change a thing is exactly what I would
do have at it
okay and then would you hold off at all
until interest rates come down and just
when we get that downtown ready no buy a
house when you're ready
okay because here's the thing if
interest rates come down after you buy
the house refinance
house prices aren't coming down
we've not seen substantial drops in
house prices ever in the real estate
market except during the 2008 debacle
and we're not going to see them now
we've told you this for two years
because we've still got a shortage of
housing
there's not enough inventory too many
buyers chasing too few items causes
price to maintain stability or go up so
house price is going to be going up and
I wouldn't sit around and watch the
house prices go up while I'm waiting on
interest rates to go down bad plan
I don't time the stock market or the
real estate market
exactly both involve some risk and
here's the only time I would time the
real estate market is if I can't find a
deal when I'm buying investment property
and then wait because the Market's like
white hot and there is no deals I'm just
don't buy unless I get a good good deal
period I do not buy investment property
unless I steal it period I want to get a
great Buy on investment property your
money's made at the Buy on that but as
far as your personal residence goes buy
when you're ready which is when you're
debt free have your emergency fund
inflation have saved your down payment
yeah and I get interest rates have got
people freaked out because you know it's
hundreds of dollars more in your payment
they're going well I need to wait the
problem like you're saying Dave is those
same people are going to call us and say
Dave I waited and now the home price is
a hundred thousand more than it was well
and there's no guarantee interest rates
come down
what if you shut around and waited and
they went to 10. yeah they just raised
the rates again so we just don't know in
1978 September I got my real estate
license I was 18. that was the year
interest rates went from nine and three
quarters to ten percent for the very
first time ever
and if it did it then and then it went
on up to 18 before it came back down and
it took it a decade to do that reversal
to go on up and then back down uh if it
did it then why can't it do it now I
mean I don't know these could these
bozos continue to screw with this
they're going to mess it up
I mean so I wouldn't be sitting around
waiting on
the outside environment to get you ready
you get ready strike while the Iron's
hot